Next Question from the point of view Of
A Woman Who is undergoing menstruation
post Natal Bleeding Is It prohibited or
optional for Them To Fast As far as the
Women Who are undergoing The menstrual
cycles or Po beding According to Beloved
prop mention buar also in Muslim that it
is Forbidden For A Woman to fast Who is
Bleeding du to menstrual cycle or poal
Bleeding
So It Is Not optional It is Forbidden
and the reason is because When The blod
Flows Out In A  lad in a woman She loses
a l of Blood and On Top of that If She
Fast It will not be good for Health
Allah It is Mercy that he exed them and
Made it comp not to fast otherwise It
May be damaging for the Health and Allah
does not want to overb Any of the human
being so That's The Reason They are exed
from fasting and and even In The Middle
Of The Day if the menstruation Begins
The have to break the fast even if it
Begins A few minutes Before Sun they have
to break the fast but  they have to
compensate later on but if the undergo  the
menstrual peri And if the per stops Just
Before f even if they do not have Bath They
can start the f but if it Ends even A
few minutes after They can not Fast The
have to Bre the f and the have to
compensate later
ok